[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com it was a very gruesome Super
Tuesday for the progressive movement in
the United States one of the things I do
not do on this program I will not do on
this program is give you unrealistic
assessments of how things are going and
I told you yesterday the momentum for
Joe Biden from his over-performing in
South Carolina
combined with the drop out and
endorsements of Pete Budaj edge and Amy
Klobuchar it is likely to propel Biden
to better results than the polling
reflects going in to yesterday's
elections and this indeed happen it was
a bad night for Bernie Sanders it was
about as good of a night as Joe Biden
could have hoped to have given where he
was just a week ago even winning in
Texas was Joe Biden which he was not
expected to win so we're going to look
at the results we're going to look at
how the results compared with the polls
we'll look at the delegate numbers we'll
analyse the path forward but what is
really important to understand bigger
picture about what's going on here is
that this has been a similar pattern in
the last several Democratic primaries
where we're going to look at this
tomorrow in 2008 and in 2016 you have a
situation where you have the polling at
the beginning of the primary and then
things start to drastically shift either
to candidates getting very very far
apart and then it reverses or to
candidates getting very very close and
then it reverses look at 2008 and look
at 2016 and look in 10 days at 2020 and
you will see a very similar pattern and
again being surprised when the same
patterns repeat themselves means we're
not paying attention we are being adults
here we are going to deal with what is
and not what we would like to be let's
start with the results there were four
ten primaries yesterday plus American
Samoa Joe Biden won nine of the
primaries Bernie won four and they're
still counting in Maine which is very
close it's within a point right now but
with 24 delegates the results there are
only going to influence the total count
to some degree it's going to be you know
a fraction of marginal difference there
Joe Biden winning in Alabama Virginia
North Carolina Tennessee Arkansas
Oklahoma Minnesota Massachusetts and
Texas Bernie Sanders winning Vermont
Colorado Utah and California although
the exact margin they are still being
tallied and then as I mentioned in Maine
in Maine the counting is still going on
Michael Bloomberg did pick up delegates
he is now in a third / fourth place in
delegate numbers based on active active
candidates we will discuss that
Elizabeth Warren did very poorly
performing at the 20 percent level only
in her home state of Massachusetts where
she came in third place and much like
Michael Bloomberg Warren clearly has no
path to the nomination at this point in
time when she gets out is increasingly a
topic of concern says she's fighting on
to the following primaries based on a
fundraising email that she sent although
at the same time there is the idea that
she is reevaluating the campaign as is
Michael Bloomberg let's now look at the
delegate numbers every website has
slightly different numbers on this but
as of right now according to the
Associated Press the delegate count is
Biden four five three and Bernie three
eight - that's a 71 delegate lead for
Joe Biden and we'll we'll discuss in a
moment why that is important and then
you see Warren and Michael Bloomberg
50th and 44th place 50 delegates and 44
delegates respectively
one thing I was paying attention to that
tells us a lot about momentum and this
is really entering the analysis of
what's to come because there are a lot
of people saying this is over for Bernie
and there are a lot of people saying
this is the beginning of the fight for
Bernie and there are a lot of Delegates
still out there which is of course
completely true
when we look at the polling and compare
it to the results if candidates do
better than the polling it's a signal
that they're carrying pent up momentum
with them including into future
elections and that's what we need to
look at and when we compare the results
to the polling what you see are good
numbers for Joe Biden again I'm just the
messenger if you look at many of these
States Joe Biden won by a larger margin
than the polling so as an example in
Alabama
Biden won by 47 he was projected to win
by 25 Biden overperformed the polls by
22 Arkansas Biden overperformed by 5
California where Bernie won
Bernie underperformed by 3 in Colorado
where Bernie won
Bernie underperformed by 1 Massachusetts
Warren and Bernie were slated to to win
one or the other
Biden won by seven over-performing
everything if you look at for example
Minnesota a Biden was supposed to lose
by five he won by nine that's a plus 14
and as you go down the list you find
that Biden overperformed basically every
state and Bernie underperformed
basically every state even Utah and
Vermont where Bernie won underperformed
the polls by 8 and by 12 so the numbers
are not particularly good for Bernie
Sanders sometimes when you look forward
you have to look at what regions are
left to vote so let's talk about that
going forward yes there are plenty of
Delegates out there yes
71 delegates as a margin Bernie Sanders
could very easily overcome in just one
night of voting but the question is
where is it going to happen and there
are all sorts of hot takes about this
it's not over Bernie's in it and they're
absolutely right Bernie can win it but
the window closes unless we can figure
out exactly where Bernie can win it
because if you add up the momentum
meaning a lot of people saw Joe Biden's
reversal yesterday
and I predict Biden's support will only
grow from this point forward too if you
look at the remaining big states they
are not good states for Bernie Sanders
example Florida has Biden plus 22 and
that's 219 delegates that's a real
problem for Bernie unless he reverses it
New York is going to be closer for sure
there's no recent polling but it could
be roughly a three-way split between
Biden and Bernie and Bloomberg if
Bloomberg gets out Biden likely wins New
York but again if it's a roughly even
split that helps Biden in the delegate
math because it just maintains his lead
we look at Michigan the latest poll in
Michigan has Biden ahead Georgia is a
big one with a hundred and five
delegates and Biden's been ahead there
since day one there's a question mark
around Ohio we don't have any recent
polls there and lastly if Bloomberg does
get out and Warren does not he's
reportedly reevaluating his campaign
today it's not clear what Biden is doing
if Bloomberg's out and Warren's in that
is even more support that's going to go
from Bloomberg to Biden and that could
be the nail in Bernie's coffin that's
the way the numbers are looking right
now so I'm here to tell you bernie has a
path and it is a steep uphill path and
it's getting to be very similar to in
2016 and what I don't want to
participate in are these completely
out-of-this-world hypotheticals where
you had I'm not even gonna name the
people a lot of them don't even really
have shows anymore their online presence
has gone away anyway so you wouldn't
even recognize the names but they were
there were all sorts of people in 2016
when it was very clear that it was over
for Bernie insisting not only that
Bernie had a shot but the Bernie had the
most likely shot I'm not going to do
that this is bad for Bernie he has a
path it depends on a reversal of
momentum it depends on changes happening
in the dynamics for this race this is
always a tough situation it happened in
2016 as well when I can't in good faith
come to you and tell you lies or blow
smoke up your whatever when I do I am
NOT a can
paying spokesperson right this is a
well-orchestrated reversal by the
democratic party
it took 96 hours to rocket Joe Biden
into the position of now being the
favorite to win this thing and the
important thing that I want to get into
because with the numbers are the numbers
and I'm telling you what they are the
polls in upcoming states are what they
are what I want to talk about is should
this be considered a wake up call to the
progressive movement and if so what kind
and that's what I want to talk about
next we've been analyzing and reviewing
the results from Super Tuesday and these
are not good results for the progressive
movement of the United States and it's
really important when we look at these
results to contextualize them not only
in terms of what they mean in terms of
issue oriented questions like support
for Medicare for all which is still high
or support for particular college
policies or whatever but it also needs
to be looked at in the context of some
of the coalition's and labeled groups
that exist and I went into detail about
the results already I won't do it again
Joe Biden building a lead of about 70
delegates over Bernie right now and
based on the polling in the remaining
states still to vote it is an uphill
battle for Bernie Sanders this is now
not about these results but the bigger
picture we knew this would happen
in the sense that we knew they'd try it
right there was a question of whether it
would work to try to coalesce the
establishment vote and so far it worked
you heard all sorts of analyses for the
last six months about Bernie's ceiling
is like 18 and then Bernie gets to 20
and that Bernie's ceiling is like 23 and
then Bernie gets to 25 and then Bernie's
ceiling is 30 and then he gets to 31 and
32 in some national polls but there was
a question of whether is there some
ceiling and when you look at Biden
cratering in the polls and focusing on
South Carolina the first racially
diverse State you have to start to say
if there is a ceiling for Bernie this is
an interesting way to test it by
focusing
that first more racially diverse state
arguably more representative of some
other parts of the country and the
Democratic electorate
Joe Biden got that boost from
congressman Clyburn winning in South
Carolina by a bigger margin than the
polls suggested and what that meant was
that voters were thinking okay if I
don't want Bernie Warren is increasingly
weak basically Biden is my choice
then Pete dropped out well if you
weren't already with Bernie then Pete
dropping out more than likely pushes you
to Joe Biden if Amy drops out which she
did and endorses Joe Biden well that's
more support for Joe Biden so the
question was is there a significant
amount of the support for other
candidates Pete and Amy as an example
that would go to Bernie Sanders or is
Biden going to get the lion's share of
Amy and Pete's supporters does a big
rally with Amy and Beto O'Rourke gets
the Pete endorsement and then they get
the results they want on Super Tuesday
with Biden even winning some states
outright like Texas and Minnesota where
he was supposed to lose he was going to
get delegates but he was supposed to
lose those states so now there's all
sorts of enlightened analyses coming out
of the woodwork you know the DNC
establishment stole it Bernie's campaign
was ganged up on
it was voter suppression insiders don't
want Bernie to be the nominee corporate
media has been boosting Biden and
hurting Bernie all along and every
single one of those has some truth to it
there is no question but we also have to
realize that bernie is not merely the
victim here because if we don't
recognize that the progressive movement
will never win and that would be a
tragedy when we see Bernie not take PAC
money we love it it's the right thing to
do it's morally correct
lots of House seats have been won in
that way but every decision has some
risk associated with it when Bernie
doesn't play these inside baseball party
politics games with the Democratic Party
where they coordinate they say let's get
Pete out let's figure out how to stop
this can--it let's get Bernie out on
this day get a me out on this day to
endorse I love that Bernie doesn't play
those games he just runs his campaigns
he tells it like he sees it he says what
he would do he puts together policy
Burnie is loved because he doesn't play
those games but in a lot of the real
world sometimes you need to play those
games to get into a position of power in
the first place to then change the
system so when we say the establishment
stole it
there's no doubt the DNC establishment
coordinated this 96-hour plan of
consolidating Amy and Budaj edges around
Joe Biden of course it was fabricated
and planned but it only works if there's
enough centrist or center-left support
to make it possible and it was so we
have to recognize that when we spend
time on Twitter and reddit we get an
overly optimistic assessment of the
portion of the National Democratic
electorate who wants someone like Bernie
that's not an attack on Bernie there's
lots of candidates that are liked excuse
me getting very fired up and punching my
Mike there's lots of candidates that are
liked and disliked by different
electorates it doesn't tell us if
they're good or bad candidates but we
have to recognize that if you ask people
about Medicare for all people are
increasingly for it if you ask people
about free college people are
increasingly for it there are lots of
people who don't want Bernie to be the
nominee and a lot of them voted last
night when so many people come out and
vote for someone other than Bernie we
can't just say people are confused and
they were tricked by the DNC and bla bla
bla bla bla because then we will not win
if that's what we do if we just say we
are the victims and everybody else's has
either been bamboozled or whatever the
case may be when you look at people
supporting Biden Pete and Amy throughout
the campaign and not going to Bernie we
tried to ignore it but there is this
total amount of center-left ideology in
the Democratic Party Medicare for all
more popular than ever free college you
zoom out and there are millions of
Democrats who believe in what they call
capitalism and they hear democratic
socialism and they don't like it
socialism viewed more favorably now than
in decades but there are lots of
Democratic primary voters who believe in
what they see as moderation this is not
an attack on anybody this is not praise
for anybody
it's assessing the electorate Bernie bet
on a ton of new voters that he could
bring out but new voters voted by
roughly the same proportion as in 2016
in some states lower new voter turnout
there is a race racial analysis to be
made Bernie won Hispanic voters with 50%
he only got 15 percent of the black vote
yesterday 60 percent for Biden young
voters a lot stayed home
another group Bernie was counting on and
then lastly there is something to be
said just more broadly about coalition's
and the people that different candidates
get involved with and sort of the the
note that that the chord that that
strikes with a more casual follower of
politics I've talked about some of the
toxic people around Bernie I can see
past it because I care about policy and
I believe Bernie has the right policies
but all over my Facebook page and
Twitter account
there were people telling me you know
David I agree with Bernie the most every
time I do one of these tests about whose
policy is closest to yours but I don't
want to implicitly approve of the toxic
people Bernie has around him and they
said so I ended up voting for Biden so
if you said to me well how could Bernie
have fixed it that would require me to
tell you that Bernie should have been
someone other than who he is the last
thing I'm going to tell you is bernie
should be inauthentic because bernie is
all about authenticity
he calls himself a democratic socialist
he has the people around him that he
wants around him Bernie refuses to do
the inauthentic stuff and this was the
result okay tons of people have been
saying Bernie needs a one-on-one against
someone else in the primary and then
he'll do really well it became very
quickly a de facto one-on-one of course
Bloomberg taking votes from Biden and
Warren likely taking votes from Bernie
we now have to go through Florida and
New York and Michigan with what is going
to effectively be a two-person race and
it may actually be one very soon there's
one other important number here which is
the popular vote right now Joe Biden has
received nearly a million votes more
than Bernie if you look at the
percentages Joe Biden has received 24%
more votes than Bernie in these
primaries when you see that
it has to be more than just the
establishment played delegate games to
sneak Biden more delegates we can't
ignore it if we in the progressive
movement ignore these numbers we will
lose now Joe Biden may be the nominee
and is very very possible he will lose
to Donald tunnel from anyway we'll talk
about that that that's a different
argument but I think it's important for
the progressive movement to have a
healthy and accurate assessment of what
is going on here and not resort to the
sort of self victimizing and blaming
everybody else for what took place
that's not going to get us anywhere and
I don't want to see that done tell me
where you disagree with me I'm ready I'm
on Twitter at a packer the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are michelle Russell and Laura mule
Houser Michelle and Laura thank you for
your support also thanks to Roger Bates
today's longtime sustaining member of
the day Rogers been a member for five
years Thank You Roger
grab a membership at join pakman.com we
also are receiving word that Michael
Bloomberg is suspending his campaign
if Michael Bloomberg is indeed out and
Warren stays in it is over for Bernie
Sanders that is for sure the lion's
share of Bloomberg's support will go to
Joe Biden and unless Warren gets out
it's over that is my prediction as of
now let's get into hatred mail for the
week hatred mail of course when a
professional voice-over artist reads the
hate mail that I get quick reminder hey
we'd probably poison our entire family
if Trump told us to but remember it's
not a cult
Patriot man written by Patriots who hate
David Pakman because America and because
freedom all right and here is this
week's hatred mail needing no
introduction whatsoever daily news kuck
boy david pakman still clueless david
chill for The Wall Street stock market
hack man poor David doesn't get it that
it doesn't matter Trump will win Trump
will win Trump will win and then you
will cry cry cry the greatest stock
market of our time and yes I am invested
not some backwater hillbilly is as you
think of is trumpets David's hair is
also insane this is funny because I've
said from the beginning I wouldn't be
surprised at all if Donald Trump is the
winner of the November 20 2011
trumpets like to pretend that it would
come as some great shock to me if Donald
Trump was reelected I've been saying for
a while I believe the most likely single
outcome is Trump reelected followed by
you know a slice that says this
Democratic candidate is the president a
slice that says this other Democratic
candidate is the president I would not
be shocked and so anybody writing to me
saying I'm gonna be the one crying
crying crying in shock on November 4th
uh the day after the election I have
been saying for a while that that is the
scenario that I am scared of but believe
is not an unlikely one so maybe you've
got this show confused with a different
one remember that you can use the coupon
code hey tree at forty h80
RI o t for zero to get 40% off a
membership at join pakman.com and when
you use that code the hey tree 'it's
become irate because they are unable to
dissuade people from supporting
independent media i hate lies i just
don't like them tell me the truth and
then tell me why I should still support
you don't lie to me and one of the lies
that Joe Biden has told is that he was
arrested when visiting South Africa in
the 1970s the story Biden has been
telling is that he was in South Africa
during the apartheid times and was
arrested and for example Biden said in
South Carolina last month quote this day
thirty years ago Nelson Mandela walked
out of prison and entered into
discussions about apartheid I had the
great honour of meeting him I had the
great honor of being arrested with our
UN Ambassador on the streets of Soweto
trying to get to see him on Robben
Island now on February 16th Joe Biden
said he got arrested trying to see
Nelson Mandela in prison and on February
18th he said the same thing again about
a story about how he got his wife Jill
to marry him it turns out all three of
those instances of claiming he was
arrested were untrue the New York Times
researched it they found no evidence
that Joe Biden was arrested in South
Africa former UN Ambassador who was on
the trip back in the 70s that tryout
that Biden refers to says I have no
recollection or knowledge of Joe Biden
getting arrested so Joe Biden was
confronted
out this and the casual nature with
which he just brushes off that he lied
multiple times about being arrested
admits he wasn't telling the truth and
then just moves on is really horrible
let's take a look at the video um I do
want to ask you about one thing that
you've said repeatedly on the trail I
think it's three times now you said that
during a visit to South Africa to visit
Nelson Mandela which I know was a very
memorable visit for you that you were
arrested when you were there your
campaign has come out since and said no
no no you were separated from other
people at the airport but you didn't say
arrests three times what why well what I
meant to say was I got off that look I
strongly strongly strongly opposed to
tarp apartheid I was one of the leaders
I mean you doubt it
go on Joe Biden calm and look at the
exchange between George Shultz and me in
the Foreign Relations Committee and
here's the deal I was in with a black
delegation the CDC the the the
Congressional Black Caucus they had me
get off a plane the copper Connors gone
on in the short pants and their guns let
me offer led me off first and move me in
a direction totally differently turn
around and everybody all the entire
black delegation was gone another way I
said I'm not going to go in that door
that says wait only I'm going with them
I said you're not you can't move you
can't go with them and they and they
kept me there until finally I decided
they were clear I wasn't going to move
and so what they finally did they said
okay they're not gonna make the
congressional delegation go through the
black door then I can make me go through
the white door they went took us out my
memory serves me through a baggage claim
area up to a restaurant and they cleared
out a restaurant I felt strongly about
apartheid one of the reasons we were
there and after long after this when
Nelson Mandela was freed and came to the
United States he came to my office it
was one of the most incredible men ever
met he sat down office thanked me
thanked me for trying to all the work I
did on apartheid I truly don't get this
I don't you lied about being arrested no
no no I was against apartheid but we're
not arguing about that Joe we're arguing
about the arrest claims and there are
two possibilities and both are both are
conceivable either Biden's memory is
gone which is a concern that's been
raised many many times or Biden was
deliberately lying when he claimed to be
arrested in South Africa thinking and
maybe it won't be fact
and that's also very very bad is it
believable by the way that someone might
have a sort of hazy recollection of
whether or not they were arrested or
merely separated from the group I was
arrested once I've told the story I was
at a party when I was 20 and I was
holding half a beer which I had not yet
even taken a sip of I was five months
shy of my 21st birthday police entered
the the party because of a noise
complaint I happened to be by the door
holding a beer and I was arrested it was
traumatic I've been at a ton of other
parties I've sometimes been separated
from my friends I've traveled all over
the world and been in all sorts of
situations there is no doubt whatsoever
in my mind I was never arrested at any
of those things
I was only arrested in July of 2004
that's the only time I was arrested it
is not hazy being arrested is traumatic
you remember it
now if Biden were someone like for
example Jane Fonda who gets herself
arrested for protesting multiple times
okay maybe you forget that I get
arrested at the Austin Texas event or
the San Antonio event or something like
that that is not this situation so I
don't know I would find it it would be
refreshing to me for Joe Biden just to
apologize for telling a story that
wasn't true and by the way for telling
it at least three times instead of what
I meant when I said I got arrested is
that I was separated from my group and I
was against apartheid during that time
in South Africa it's not good it's not
good folks will follow up on this on our
Instagram account at David Pakman show
follow me on Instagram at David Pakman
we will take a very brief break and be
right back
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome back to the david
pakman show I'm thrilled to welcome to
the program today dr. patch Adams who is
a world-renowned doctor clown and
activist who believes that the health
and diseases of individuals really can't
be separated from the health and
diseases of their communities of their
country of the world he's also director
of the ghazan tight Institute which is a
nonprofit organization focused on
healing the financial and social traumas
of our for-profit health care system dr.
Adams it's so great to have you on I
really appreciate it
can we call me patch yes create
hierarchy let's do it let's do it patch
so listen there the conversation around
how care is delivered to people has been
so front and center in the current
Democratic presidential primary it's
been a front and center topic since the
United States adopted Obama care about
ten years ago where do you think the
conversation around this issue is just
completely missing the mark well I think
most of the conversation is around
trying to do something with the problems
rather than giving a great vision our
work has been knowing the problems and
creating a great vision and when you
think about that vision does it line up
with the system that any country around
the world currently has no it doesn't
know can you say more about that why not
what is missing from the systems around
the world can I describe what we're
doing yes okay I entered medical school
in 1967 because I thought doctoring was
a love job for men I quickly within a
month found out but there was nothing I
liked about the system that I was
hearing about and seeing in the
hospitals most doctors were rude and
arrogant and hierarchical and there
wasn't any fun or love or these kinds of
things in a hospital setting it was
frenetic and yeah and so I am happy to
say I am a nerd so I didn't have to
study much in medical school I spent my
time deciding what kind of health system
I would like and I did that and when I
graduated nobody gave me a hospital I
guess they're expensive so I did what
people in the 60s did 20 of us moved
into a six bedroom house and said we
were a hospital open 24/7 and in the 12
years we operated we had about 500 to a
thousand people in our home each month
with five 250 overnight guests a night
in a six bedroom house that already had
20 adults and its children living there
so let's say it was intimate yes and I
wanted a hospital setting that was happy
funny loving cooperative creative and
thoughtful that that's a climate for
good health and a climate for non Verna
because so often in wanting to change
the healthcare system it's more about
helping the patient's get what they need
rather than the staff gets what they
need so all of this time I'm in the 50th
year of fundraising for a project I
thought would take four to find the
funding because our design eliminated
90% of the cost of care
that's what I want to focus in on can
you talk about how 90 you know people
talk about we can eliminate 3% with some
bureaucratic simplification we can look
at unnecessary testing to get another 5%
how do you wish a Chiva 90% reduction in
cost well put on your seat belt yes
okay so we have 327 acres in Pocahontas
County West Virginia the poorest state
for health care in the u.s. yes we want
to build a 40 bed primary care rural
community hospital on that land all of
the permanent staff would live there as
a communal eco village I'm thinking a
hundred and 20 permanent staff and that
everyone from the cleaning person to the
surgeon would make the same salary hold
your seat $300 a month okay
the hospital will be an extensive
permaculture farm and artists colony and
I feel that we with that design we we
won't accept health insurance no one
will have to fill out any of those forms
and we'll we'll practice medicine an
interesting addition is that we we found
in the 12 years we were practice even
though we often did it illegally at the
time that acupuncture homeopathy
naturopathy area Vedic anthroposophical
all had a role in medicine the only one
that was non allopathic that was legal
in my state was chiropractic and we
found all of them were great additions
to what we learned that's interesting so
you're most physicians tend to take the
view that on something like homeopathy
there there may well be some kind of
placebo benefit but for example many
homeopathic substances have no active
ingredients and thus they don't really
do anything you as a physician take a
different approach well when I try to
check out a healing approach I asked the
healers that do it okay so for faith
healing if you don't think faith healing
has any effect don't do it or or at
least don't push it
homeopathy which is all over the world
and I've seen it do great things the
weaker the the homeopathic remedy often
the stronger which goes against
everything we were taught but one could
question the value for example in mental
illness in 50 years of practice I never
disliked a patient enough to give a
psychiatric diagnosis or a psychiatric
medication okay and so there are lots of
points of view out there I mean
acupuncture if I rub this point here and
it got rid of 80% of the headaches in 48
years of rubbing that point on both
sides
and how does rubbing a point in the hand
affect a headache
in allopathic medicine it would be
called quackery rights so the concept
would be all the doctors get paid 300
bucks a month $3,600 for the year that
drastically reduces all of the staff
yeah doctors included everybody gets
$3,600 for the year yeah you do
Ayurvedic as well as homeopathic
medicine and this cuts costs by ninety
percent now will you be fully staffed in
terms of if somebody needs you know a
heart related and aortic valve
replacement will you be able to do
something like that well that's why I
said primary
care ah good okay so there are heart
surgeries that are primary care there
are that our tertiary care and so if if
the doctor at the surgeons we have feel
comfortable we'll do it and where do you
think that you will find the medical
staff that is interested in in that
salary of $3,600 a year well a bonus of
being in the fiftieth year rather than
the first year and adding to that fame
when we closed our doors in 83 within a
year I felt a real intense absence of
care I need to care I'm one of those
people and I didn't have a hospital and
so I decide I couldn't go and work in a
regular Hospital that that would hurt me
and so I did I added two kinds of care
what was Clown trips and I've done
clowned trips all over the world in fact
the last Russia trip that we had had
eight doctors and five nurses because
they wanted to put more humor in their
practice and the other thing I did was
answer mail so in these years I've
answered 400,000 letters from a hundred
and thirty nine countries well from all
over the world
I hear discontent in medical doctors and
in nurses that hate what they're doing
they hate the context they the hospitals
are unhappy they're miserable and this
is pretty well known in this country as
well and so you know one can decide that
rich has many meanings rich is good
friends hmm rich is doing exactly what
you want in the way that you want yes
rich is having good health are you
getting what I'm saying absolutely
on our land there are three waterfalls a
four acre lake
they're beaver otter deer wild turkey
it's it's a natural paradise and you get
to practice medicine so as a family
doctor I like my initial interview with
an adult to be 3 or 4 hours long because
we're complicated well and I want to
have so much time that we fall in love
with each other that the friendship
between health professional and patient
can often be the medicine they need
right
and Pat you were portrayed by the late
Robin Williams in the film patch Adams
which is of course based based on your
life and your views on medicine that
that you've told us a little bit about
here how did you feel about that
portrayal do you feel that it was an
accurate portrayal of you well I loved
Robin his personality though he was much
more introverted than I he he was a
wonderful playmate and he cares so the
movie wanted to sell tickets they
promised to build us and did not and I
mean they changed what they wanted to
change so the real person murdered was
not my girlfriend but my closest male
friend in medical school that was the
thing I disliked the most the creative
liberties they took right they they
didn't want to change the future of
healthcare they wanted to sell a Robin
Williams movie and they did didn't they
oh it was a huge seller yeah I I spanked
their bottom that they did not build our
hospital so explain that they had made
an intimation that they would support
your hospital with some of the proceeds
build it they said we'll build the
hospital well you know Fame is a
nightmare
and so I needed something and by that
time enough time had passed where I
wanted a hospital and
I knew that they would make enough to be
rich themself and I wanted to hide it I
didn't want the money
I wanted a hospital and it did not
materialize right Wow Wow
well yes Yaga had I asked they didn't
answer the letters they didn't respond
to that wow that is that is an
incredible story well doctor perhaps
yeah are you ninety percent of the
people who have said patch I'm gonna
send you some money didn't do it either
why do you think that is I think that's
the world we live in a sad reality you
know I've never been discouraged it's
really fun to work for something
beautiful there great members of the
team and I'm having fun along the way
I've climbed at ten thousand death beds
in Trinidad I clown for five men who
were hung the next morning for capital
crimes or loved it because of our work
groups of clowns are going in hospitals
in a hundred and forty countries to try
the up the vibe I guess and so I'm not
going oh darn we haven't built right the
hospital may not have materialized but
so many other things have correct right
and and we're not the only people trying
to change healthcare delivery and and
yet it hasn't been changing much right
that's for sure that's for sure listen
dr. patch Adams it's been such a
pleasure speaking with you and you
sharing a little bit about your life and
what you've done I I encourage my
audience to learn more about what you're
doing including at the ghazan type
instance
and I so appreciate your time today the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
Donald Trump had a rally in the Super
Tuesday state of North Carolina and he
went into a bizarre diatribe because of
a potentially Mexican audience member
and in the video you're going to see
Donald Trump point to someone in the
audience and start to say he's Mexican
and then he says but wait are you
Mexican no way you're Mexican you are
you aren't no way that guy is Mexican
he's as Mexican as I am it's genuinely
hard to tell whether Donald Trump is
shocked that there might really be a
Mexican person at one of his rallies
maybe it's a light-skinned Mexican which
Donald Trump might not know exists
Donald Trump not particularly familiar
with Central and South America I don't
know what's going on here but it is very
very weird
where do you live like this guy he's a
Mexican you're about as Mexican as I am
look at this guy
he's as Mexican as I am look at that hat
are you Mexican are you Mexican no
you're not are you he is
it's like Elizabeth Warren she said she
was an Indian I said right I said I have
more Indian blood in me than you have
and I have none and she said oh this is
terrible so she went out and got a test
and it turned out not so good for her
right extremely strange and of course
has to throw in Elizabeth Warren Indian
references as well can you guys believe
that this is the world that we're in
today that this is what we're living in
in 2020 the president ranting and raving
about a possibly Mexican audience member
is it notable this of course is upper
Trump as we discussed yesterday with
psychiatrist dr. Justin Frank this
reminds me of when Donald Trump spotted
a black guy in the audience and started
to yell about my african-american
remember this abortive rally from the
campaign we had a case where we had an
african-american guy who is a fan of
mine great fan great guy in fact I want
to find out what's going on with him you
know what I look at my african-american
over here look at him are you the
greatest do you know what I'm talking
about okay so we have an
african-american guy at one of the
rallies a month ago this is sort of a
concept for rally
Tyrael Trump used to just read poll
numbers totally out of context at
rallies a new direction to go would be
evaluate the perceived Rea --then s and
ethnicity of people in the crowd maybe
turn it into some kind of game show
because that's effectively what we're
dealing with right now and then of
course we got to the moment in the rally
when Donald Trump glitched glitching
this time specifically on the word
banker you'll hear it if you're watching
you'll also see that shoulder spasm that
we discussed yesterday with psychiatrist
dr. Justin Frank talked about that
phenomenon that is often notable with
Trump take a look so they don't have to
go back to the evil bank and borrow
money from the banker and lose the farm
lose the business it won't happen and I
always say it because you know I know a
lot of parents another day another
glitch and then lastly this is almost
satirical at this point Trump bragged
about yesterday's of the day before
yesterday's large increase in the stock
market ignoring of course that it was an
erratic rebound from last week's fastest
10 percent decline in the stock market
in history which Trump blamed on the
democratic debate then here is Trump
taking credit for the erratic rebound
day that the stock market had this is an
incredible time for our nation our
country is stronger than ever before and
today we just had the largest one-day
increase in the stock market in history
imagine cheering for that the fastest
10% decrease ever the week before you
get a partial rebound followed by the
way yesterday with another thousand
point loss and Trump has the crowd
cheering about the one day in the
interlude of erratic stock market
insanity and they're just cheering and
absolutely loving it and then by the way
here's Trump yesterday yesterday the
stock market crashed again Trump asked
about it he says oh no I have it I
haven't seen the numbers I haven't seen
it I'm focused on this the country is in
great shape the market is in great shape
I'm focused on this this is very
important what luck right Trump only has
the availability and the time in his
schedule to follow the stock market on
days where the stock market is up
amazing coincidence
so anyway another Trump rally filled
with what you would expect to hear from
the senile guys that go to your local
watering hole at 10:30 p.m. on a Tuesday
night more so than what would be suited
for a presidential rally and a President
of the United States this is where we
are in 2020 the way the primary is going
we may be in this situation until
January of 2025 as utterly insane as
that sounds
Trump would be what 78 at that point in
time this is scary stuff and I'm I'm
worried that that's the direction in
which we are going I got a hilarious
email yesterday which I want to share
with you Liz wrote to me and Liz said
here's some feedback from me I am a
member when 99% of the world refers to
the virus as coronavirus does it make
you feel special and superior to use the
term kovat 19 repeatedly on your show
personally I find it irritating and a
sign of your arrogance it's a tell and
while I'm at it I will give you some
more feedback regarding your arrogance
your sexist dismissal of Suzy Ormond who
you obviously know nothing about so I'm
gonna ignore the Suzy Orman part I don't
even remember mentioning Suzy Orman
other than she's given some scam
financial advice over the last 20 years
let's focus on kovat 19 so Liz noticed
this and other people also notice this
I've been avoiding the word coronavirus
in my stories and what I say I've been
avoiding it in YouTube titles and in
YouTube descriptions and the reason I'm
doing that is YouTube has notified me
that anything even mentioning
coronavirus is completely and totally
not monetizable so I've been trying to
find other ways to describe it sometimes
I'll say they're looking for a vaccine
for the pandemic virus or I'll say the
latest data in the virus outbreak
sometimes I'll say koban 19
unfortunately these techniques also
aren't working and on Monday there was a
lot of coronavirus coronavirus news from
the weekend I'm saying it now because
obviously this video is is is a lost
cause
Monday more than half of our show was
demonetised even the stories that were
mostly about trump saying things where
something about coronavirus was like an
aside even those videos were demonetized
I've told YouTube I've told every one of
my contacts at YouTube this is crazy
this is a public interest story this is
a public health story it's not gory it's
not violent it's not salacious we have a
pressing health concern and they say now
sorry it's not ad friendly and even
worse because not only are independent
media stories about the virus not
monetizable there are ads that run on my
videos people will get a pre-roll ad on
one of my videos from another news
outlet covering coronavirus which makes
no sense whatsoever so it's not
arrogance I'm not trying to make you
think I'm smart or anything like that
it's certainly not sexist or anything
like it it's that we have to cover this
it's an important issue it's a public
health issue and in doing so we lose
money so I'm creatively trying to get
around saying coronavirus so far it's
not working too well but for upcoming
stories that's why you might might see
me vaguely say the outbreak the virus or
sometimes
kovat 19 if it's annoying I apologize in
advance we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p i
have a couple of sad voicemails to play
for you today
they are unfortunately from Bernie
supporters who are despondent after
super Tuesday's Fiasco only compounded
now Michael Bloomberg dropping out and
endorsing Joe Biden I believe it is over
and I know people will be furious
I believe it's over and I understand the
frustration take a listen to this hey
David after seeing the results of Super
Tuesday
I don't think Bernie's got it in them I
don't think he's gonna get the support
to win the nomination and I think that
his supporters they're not all of them
but really loud ones online are very
delusional and are probably not going to
show up to vote especially for Joe Biden
when he went and I think we're screwed
I think Trump's going to win re-election
as a result of this and I honestly think
there's secretly a lot of these Bernie
supporters that I'm referring to not all
of them obviously but the most loud
delusional ones actually supports Trump
I don't think they support Trump but I
think they would rather Trump over Joe
Biden which is not something I agree
with let's listen to another one of
these very sad messages hey David Steve
from Florida after a loss on Super
Tuesday for Bernie Sanders it
increasingly looks like Joe Biden may be
the nominee
given the coronavirus and people not
having health care do you think that his
path to victory needs to include a
medicare-for-all where he can abandon
his more centrist stance on enhanced
Obamacare and moved to the left to
picked up Bernie supporters I I don't I
actually I actually think that what Joe
Biden is going to need to do
particularly if the kovat 19 outbreak
spreads is he's going to have to exact
explain exactly how those infected with
the virus would be able to afford care
for it as well as testing
the issue of the testing and the cost of
the testing has become a big thing he
would have to explain how under his plan
that would work and whether we find it
believable whether we find it a
satisfactory explanation is obviously an
open question but I don't believe that
it is going to be necessary for Biden to
do that in the context of the broader
electorate remember and that is that
that's my take as of right now and of
course that could change is the
situation on the ground with coronavirus
such shifts and changes but I hear I
hear the despondency I hear it and it
was a very disappointing night for the
progressive movement as of right now
Elizabeth Warren is still in the race I
believe even if Elizabeth Warren drops
out that a significant portion of her
support actually doesn't go to Bernie
anyway so I know that this is being seen
as sort of look the last stand for
Bernie will Warren drop out so that
Bernie will gain her support I think
even with an endorsement of Bernie and
Warren dropping out I still think
probably anywhere from twenty to forty
percent of her support goes to bite in
anyway and with Bloomberg at this point
dropping out and endorsing Biden III
tell you guys you know in the Indy time
it took us to film today's show I've
gone from it's an uphill battle for
Bernie but now as we've seen Bloomberg
drop and all of these other things
happen I believe that this is basically
the end of the road for Bernie Sanders
we've got to do the rest of the
primaries for sure but that's where I am
right now I want to be wrong tell me
where I'm wrong get in touch I just
don't see the numbers and we'll
certainly talk about this more on
today's bonus show I hope you will join
me we will also talk about Genki Gore's
results in the California 25th district
special election and a primary and so
much more
grab a membership at join pakman.com
become a patron at patreon.com slash
david packard bell
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]